halli hallo und herzlich willkommen hier
in meinem Studium yogabahn Berlin ich
bin Jana und da seht ihr die Liebe
Vanessa und ich werde euch undter lieben
Vanessa eine schöne kleine Meditation
mitgeben für die vielleicht für den ein
oder anderen etwas stressige
Vorweihnachtszeit man munkelt ja und ich
höre dass der eine oder andere doch
schon ganz schön gestresst ist gerade
das heißt Geschenk gefähen wo feiern wir
Weihnachten was gibt zu essen wen will
ich alles sehen schaffe ich das
überhaupt noch und so weiter ihr wisst
ja selber was da bei euch im Kopf
wahrscheinlich gerade so abgeht und was
kann uns natürlich dabei helfen ist
Meditation Meditation hilft
grundsätzlich und wenn es nur zwei oder
dre Minuten sind einmal kurz hinsetzen
atmen fokussieren und die Welt sieht
danach ganz anders aus und ihr werd es
jetzt sehen wir machen jetzt einfach mal
eine kleine Meditation mit so zwei ich
würde sagen ich gebe mal so zwei Impulse
mit in der Meditation die euch helfen
wird einfach vielleicht so ein bisschen
den Stress zu reduzieren an erster
Stelle erstmal ein einen schönen
bequemen Sitz ihr seht es bei uns wir
haben hier so eine schönen Sitzkissen
das muss kein Meditationskissen sein ein
Kissen habt ihr alle zu Hause wenn das
nicht da ist dann nehmt ihr eine Decke
faltet die einmal doppelt setzt euch
drauf erhöht nicht platt drauf setzen
sondern rutschon ein bisschen nach vorne
vielleicht das Sitzfleisch so ein
lustiges Wort im Yoga Sitzfleisch aber
es heißt nmer so man kann auch
poofleisch vielleicht sagen rausziehen
dass du die Sitzbeinhöcker richtig gut
spürst eine leichte Kippbewegung im
Becken entsteht Knie rutschen nach unten
Wirbelsäule aufrichten damit die Energie
gut fließen kann schaue dass der Nacken
lang ist Kind ist parallel zum Boden die
Hände gern auf die Knie oder
Oberschenkel legen da haben wir auch
gleich so ein Impuls mer die Schulter
nach hin zu Zehen das Herz zu öffnen und
dann schließen wir mal direkt die
e so jetzt hast du erstmal die Augen
geschlossen und jetzt lade ich Dich
erstmal ein in den Sitz noch mal
reinzuspüren fühlt es sich jetzt alles
gut an oder willst du noch mal was
ändern noch mal ein bisschen irgendwas
bewegen und sobald du das Gefühl hast
jetzt ist alles schick du fühlst dich
wohl dann ruhig noch mal mit der
Einatmung die Schultern nach oben ziehen
und so richtig schön satt mit der
Ausatmung die Schultern nach hinten
unten noch mal spüren das Herz ist jetzt
geöffnet und dann ganz wichtig entspann
mal das Gesicht klingt immer so einfach
aber wir haben fast 80% am Tag die
zehneinander aufinander gebissen vor
allem wenn wir uns ärgern gerade zur
Weihnachtszeit Mutti hat in was
schlimmes gesagt die Schwester geht mir
auf den Sack also bei Zähn aufeinander
zwischendurch Mund auf Zähne lösen
vielleicht mal die Zunge so rausstrecken
das lockert dein Kiefergelenk und das
ist ganz wichtig umso entspannt und
locker der Kiefer ist umso entspannter
und locker sind auch unsere Schultern
unser ganzer
Oberkörper die Augen geschlossen und
jetzt gehen wir nach innen so dass du
weg vom außen gehst mal alles das was
jetzt gerade um dich herum so abgeht
gedanklich was auch immer lass das mal
raus und verbinde dich mal wirklich ganz
bewusst mit dir selbst indem du jetzt
den Fokus auf die Atmung
legst und zunächst einmal lade ich Dich
ein spür mal rein wo nimmst du jetzt
gerade den Atem war wo im Körper spürst
du deinen
Atem das mehr im
Bauchraum vielleicht mehr im
Brustkorb oder vielleicht sogar eher die
Kehle einfach mal wahrnehmen wo kannst
du den Atem jetzt gerade
spüren und dann bleibt da bei dem Punkt
wo du gerade wahrnimmst und wo den Atem
spürst und jetzt beobachte mal was macht
der Atem beobachte einfach mal wie der
Atem kommt und
geht und während wir atmen das passiert
einfach das machen wir nicht aktiv es
ist so ein Gefühl wie als wärden wir
eigentlich unser Leben lang beatmet der
Atem kommt und geht passieren h ganz
kleine Sachen im Körper und vielleicht
kannst Du diese ganz kleinen minimalen
Bewegung jetzt wahrnehmen wie die
Bauchdecke sich hebt und
senkt vielleicht kannst Du spüren wie
der Brustkorb sich hebt und
senkt vielleicht kannst Du wahrnehmen
wie die Schultern sich heben und
senken und spür dabei wie der Atem ganz
natürlich fließt kommt und
geht richtig schön entspanntes Atem der
Atem ist auch der hauptanker in der
Meditation der uns Arm mit unds selbst
verbindet vor allem in
Stresssituation und uns etwas ruhiger
werden vielleicht spürst du es jetzt
sogar schon meistens hilft schon eine
Minute oder
zwei dann kannst du zusätzlich jetzt
noch wenn du das Gefühl hast ist okay
aber irgendwie mein Monkey me und die
ganzen Gedanken und doch noch scheiße
für fah fehlt noch das Geschenk ist
schon wieder da gebe ich dir jetzt ein
Mantra mit dazu damit du noch mehr von
de Monkey mind abgelenkt wirst das heißt
du sagst jetzt während du atmest auch
dass du atmest immer leiseen Gedanken
für dich sag dir mal wenn du ein ich
atme ein und wenn du ausatmest ich atme
aus immer wieder schön wiederholen ich
atme
ein und ich atme
aus ich atme
ein und ich atme aus wenn du jetzt sagst
das ist dir zu viel gelabert zu viel
Worte dann sag einfach nur ein und aus
auch das ist vollkommen okay einfach nur
mit der Einatmung
ein und
aus
und spätestens jetzt spürst du du
vielleicht mehr und mehr angekommen
bist der Geist ruhiger wird und du
vielleicht noch etwas präsenter im Hier
und Jetzt bist in diesem
Moment und du kannst das für dich ganz
alleine jeden Tag vielleicht nur für 5
Minuten praktizieren gerade in der
Weihnachtszeit nimm die 5 Minuten hat
man selbst wenn es gerade ein ganz ganz
stressiger Moment ist in der Familie
gehst du 5 Minuten auf Toilette setzt
dich hin wo auch immer Du ein Raum für
dich
findest setzt dich hin schließ die Augen
und beobachtest den Atem und sagst dir
dass du atmest die ganze Zeit und du
wirst merken die Welt sieht danach ganz
anders
aus und falls dir die Bewegungslosigkeit
schwer
fällt kannst du deine Hände in der
Meditation Nutzen für einen weiteren
Impuls von mir drehen wir jetzt die
Handflächen nach oben so dass die
Handflächen nach oben zeigen und jetzt
gebe ich dir ein Mantra mit was für
gerade für die Weihnachtszeit ich finde
ich persönlich sehr hilfreich ist und
das Mantra heißt Frieden beginnt bei mir
und während du das Mantra leisen
Gedanken für dich immer wiederholst
lässt du die Fingerkuppen sich berühren
bei jedem Wort und zwar bei dem Wort
Frieden Daumen und Zeigefinger beginnt
Daumen und Mittelfinger bei Daumen und
Ringfinger mir darmen und kleiner Finger
ja und dann kannst du die Hände ganz
entspannt auf den Knien auf den
Oberschenkeln ruhen lassen und dann für
dich wiederholen und immer ganz sanft
die fingerguppen aufeinander legen
Frieden beginnt bei
mir und das machst du das kannst du auch
einfach 5 Minuten machen vielleicht wenn
die Zeit sich zu lang anfüht macht das 2
Minuten und wenn du sagst das Mantra
gefällt dir nicht dann nimmst du ein
anderes sei komplett kreativ du kannst
sagen ich mag mich selbst
was auch immer passt kannst du dir
aussuchen ich persönlich liebe das
Frieden beginnt bei
mir dann noch mal richtig schön tief
einatmen und vielleicht mal so lösend
aus noch mal
so ja Seufzen stöen hilft uns auch
Emotionen los lassen und dann kannst du
langsam zurückkommen einmal die Äuglein
vielleicht langsam öffnen
und mal reinspüen wie es dir jetzt so
geht
wunderbar auf jeden Fall mit Sicherheit
etwas entspannter und ruhiger ja Puls
ist runtergefahren Nervensystem ist
runter da oben ist ich ein bisschen
ruhiger bis der nächste Stress kommt die
nächste Streiterei dann werde ich aber
wieder zurückkommen
[Musik]
genau weiter geht's an unserem Christmas
morgen oder auf Deutsch auch
Weihnachtsmorgen genannt hier in
Deutschland der 24 heißt für viele noch
Last Minute Geschenke kaufen Scheiße
Bratensoße fehlt noch Rotkohl fehlt noch
ich muss los Mama macht das papa macht
das Schwester du holst da und dann noch
die Eier aus und so weiter und so fort
aber jetzt geht's darum dass wir einmal
so uns noch mal kurz Zetteln uns bereit
machen mit dem bisschen Yoga ein
bisschen Bewegung bereit machen für den
Weihnachtstag und die Besinnlichkeit am
Abend gehen wir jetzt noch mal in die
Bewegung damit wir ein bisschen Energie
hochholen und uns fät auch ein bisschen
bewegen noch von der großen
Fresserei Vanessa ja okay ihr seht
Vanessa ja neben
mir wie immer Wahnsinn dass du da
bist und wir beginnen einfach mal würde
ich sagen direkt oder setzt euch gerne
mal in ein Schneidersitz wir machen es
auch nicht zu lang dafür jederzeit kurz
ein paar bisschen Bewegung bisschen
stretchen bisschen paar Sonnengrüße
Schneidersitz und dann einmal direkt die
ein mit der Einatmung die Arme über die
Seite mal nach oben ziehen und mit der
Ausatmung die Arme wieder über die Seite
nach unten gern mal durch den Mund noch
mal Einatmen Arme über die Seite nach
oben und ausatmen die Arme über die
Seite nach
oben letztes Mal Einatmen Arme über die
Seite nach oben und jetzt aufgepasst
Ausatmen wir gehen in den Twist nach
rechts TST nach rechts genau bringen die
rechte Hand nach hinten die linke Hand
außen an dem oberschenk oder m Knie mit
der Einatmung schieb dich noch mal
richtig schön raus raus raus langer
Rücken mit der Ausatmung Twiste hier
Twists übrigens super für die Verdauung
regt die Verdauung an würde ich in der
Weihnachtszeit euch empfehlen täglich zu
machen Twists ja noch mal richtig schön
Einatmen langer langer Rücken und mit
der Ausatmung Twist du dich hier noch
ein bisschen mehr auf dreh dich noch mal
ein bisschen mehr nach hinten vielleicht
spürst du schon der Brustwirbelsäule
hier die Sitzbeinhöcker unten das Gesäß
ppöchen bleibt schön geerdet noch ein
letztes Mal tief ein Schultern nach
unten entspannen aus mit der nächsten
Einatmung kommen wir zurück zur Mitte
Schwung voll die Arme hoch noch mal und
mit der Ausatmung genüsslich und satt
über zur anderen Seite nach links linke
Hand geht nach hinten rechte Hand außen
am knieoberschenkel noch mal richtig
schön rausschieben den Rücken lang
machen und dann mit der nächsten
Ausatmung Twiste dich noch mal ein
Stückchen weiter Schultern weg vom Ohr
Bauchnabel mit der Einatmung denk dran
der Bauch geht immer mit der Einatmung
raus und mit der Ausatmung ziehst du den
Bauchnabel richtig schön rein tief
einatmen hier Ausatmen noch mal ein
Millimeter weiter
twisten noch zwei mehr tief
einatmen und ausatmen Schultern nach
unten entspannen und letztes Mal
Ausatmen Twist jetzt kommen wir einatmen
wieder zurück zur Mitte schwunkvoll die
Arme nach oben ziehen aufgepasst
Ausatmen lehn dich mal nach rechts bring
die Rechten Fingerkuppen zum Boden und
zieh den linken Arm langb ohhfläche zeig
nach oben dass du schön die Dehnung in
der linken Flanke spürst genau atme tief
ein ausatmen noch ein Stückchen weiter
rüber Lehen Schultern sind weg vom Ohr
Sitz Bein Höcker bleiben geerdet super
tief ein machst du sehr schön Wand
Ausatmen tief einatmen und noch mal ein
Stückchen mehr rüber Ausatmen Einatmen
kommen nach oben hoch beide Arme hoch
und ausatmen rüber Switch zur anderen
Seite linke Hand zum Boden rechter Arm
lang übers Ohr Handfläche zeigt nach
unten von der rechten Hand genau zieh
ruhig den rechten Daumen so ein bisschen
mehr nach hinten um das Herz nach oben
zu öffnen genau und schön die Flanke
rechts gedehnt die Sitz Bein Höcker
bleiben schön satt geerdet tief ein und
ausatmen und übrigens ganz ganz wichtig
in der Yogapraxis ist der Atem nicht nur
beim Stress und beim Weihnachtsessen
nicht den Luft anhalten sondern auch
beim Yoga immer atmen Nase ein Nase aus
der Atem führt uns Einatmen wieder hoch
zur Mitte und ausatmen die Arme über die
Seite noch mal nach hinten jetzt könnt
ihr entweder über die Knie wenn man
keine Knieprobleme hat nach vorne rollen
in den vierfußstand bei Knieproblem
auflesen Bein über die Seite nach hinten
vierfußstand da treffen wir uns gern so
mittig auf eurer Matte ganz wichtig
Ausrichtung hier immer Gelenke
üinanderstabeln heißt Handgelenk kommt
direkt unter Schultergelenk die Finger
sind richtig schön aufgespreizt ich sage
ich liebe froschfinger große große
froschfinger oder wie bei der ganz hat
die auch a ne die haben die V heute okay
wollte ich gerade noch das weihnachtsz
aufgreifen geht nicht ganz auf egal wir
drehen die Hände ein bisschen nach außen
dass die Zeigefinger nach vorne zeigen
dann hast du auch eine leichte
Außenrotation in den Schultern genau
Knie bitte Hüft schmal direkt unter der
Hüfte sieht super aus lass uns mal durch
ein bisschen Kett und kau fließen es
mobilisiert die Wirbelsäule mit der
Einatmung Herz nach vorne durchschieben
Schultern ziehen nach hinten so leicht
geführtes rohkreuz und mit der Ausatmung
machst du hier den Rücken rund Kind zum
Brustbein schieb die schulterblad
auseinander Einatmen Herz schiebt vor
und Schultern gehen nach hinten leicht
geführtes Hohlkreuz Ausatmen schön
runder Rücken Einatmen wieder Herz nach
vorne durchschieben und ausatmen runder
Rücken drei mehr Einatmen du kannst auch
in deinem eigenem Atemrhythmus machen
und ausatmen wgenen mir auch dabei die
eelen
schließen zwei mehr tief
einatmen und noch mal vollständig
ausatmen letztes Mal tief
ausatmen neutrale Position und jetzt
vielleicht mit den Händen bisschen nach
vorne wandern weil wir wollen jetzt in
den hohen Liegestütz kommen wichtig
schulterhgelenke eine Linie lassen aus
den Schultern rausdrücken dass man nicht
reinsinkt genau Bauchnabel rein als West
den unteren Rücken rund machen so
scharbein nach oben ziehen super schiee
Ebene heißt dann rechtes Bein nach
hinten strecken linkes Bein daneben
halte mal kurz das ist so richtig schön
meistens anstrengend kann man sich mal
so ein Timer stellen eine Minute halten
vielleicht ganz gut wenn man viel
gefressen hat nach der ganz nach den
Klößen Fersen schieben nach hinten Bein
aktiv ob Schinkel aktiv atme tief ein
und dann genüsslich mit der Ausatmung in
den ersten herabschauenden Hund den Po
nach hinten oben rausschieben richtig
weit mit den Händen schiebst du dich
raus Gesäß der höchste Punkt und wenn du
hier in deinem ersten wahrscheinlich
erster Hund heute am Weihnachtsmorgen
angekommen bist lauf mal auf der Stelle
so ein bisschen die Beine im Wechsel
anbeugen dann spürst du vielleicht die
Dehnung in der beiden Rückseite auch
noch
mal nimmst deinen ganzen Körper hier
wahr hier wird die ganze körperrückseite
aufgedehnt auch noch mal wenn du magst
kannst auch mal den Kopf ausschütteln
noch mal ja Ja Nein Nein Bewegung
vielleicht noch mal die Lippen
ausprusten diese sogenannten
pferdelippen die lösen sp im Gesicht ja
vielleicht merkt ihr das auch wenn man
so anstrengende Gespräche hat oder an
Weihnachten Streit ist dann sieht man
immer die anstrengenden Gesichter von
dem
Gegenüber das kann man ein bisschen
auflockern indem man dann einfach mal
macht spätestens dann schmunzelt
vielleicht der ein oder andere wieder
Fersen schieben bisschen mehr nach außen
zieh ein bisschen mehr nach innen komm
mal in den ruhigen statischen Hund zieh
die Oberschenkel hoch schieb das Becken
nach oben zie den Bauchnabel nach innen
schieb dich mit den Händen richtig raus
Finger sind gespreizt Schultern weg von
den Ohren die oh dabei bitte auf Höhe
der Oberarme ne Schulterblatt Spitzen
schieben in die imaginären Hosentaschen
nach hinten oben
raus super ganz ganz langsam laufen wir
zum Anfang der Matte dabei kannst du
gleichzeitig auf die Fingerkuppen kommen
und so Schritt für Schritt zum Anfang
der Matte laufen lass gerne die Füße
hüftschmal geöffnet lass die Knie mal
gebeugt lass dich hier so ein bisschen
hängen nach unten noch mal lass die
wirbelsule
aushängen Wasen des Wortes hier kann ja
mal alles den Buckel runterrutschen was
dich gerade ein bisschen stresst und
nervt auch noch mal ne gleich noch mal
die gegenüberlegenden Ellenbogen greifen
noch mal richtig schön hängen lassen
alles abfallen lassen vielleicht ein
letzter Seufzer hier auch noch mal
solche
genau das hilft auch ungemein Stress
loszulassen lass die Hände nach unten
fallen lass den Kopf locker und räum mal
ganz langsam mit gebeugten Knien um den
unteren Rücken zu schützen Wirbel für
Wirbel nach oben auf
yes herzlich willkommen noch
mal der Kreislauf gleich ein bisschen in
Schwung gekommen schon ja oder g jetzt
wird's ein bisschen dynamischer gucken
wir mal das ein bisschen in schwitzen
auch kommen ein paar Sonnengrüße ready
super wir machen mal über vorne dass wir
uns nicht gegenseitig klatschen ne die
Arm vorne nach oben mach die schön lang
Ausatmen beug die Knie und komm in die
Vorbeuge sehr schön Einatmen halbe
vorbeug gern die Hände dafür an die
schien mach mal den Rücken ganz lang und
mit der Ausatmung die Hände wieder zum
Boden jetzt treten wir mit dem rechten
Fuß ganz ganz weit nach hinten großer
Schritten sehr gut linker daneben in die
schiefe Ebene hatten wir gerade schön
halten Bauch aktiv rausdrücken tief
einatmen super Ausatmen die Knie zum
Boden
mbogen ziehen nach hinten leg mal die
Brust zwischen die Händer jetzt kommen
wir in die Cobra scharbein Füße lang
machen lass den Nacken lang heb den
Oberkörper Körper ein bisschen hoch
super Ausatmen sttirb die Zehen um und
schie dich wieder zurück in den
herabschauenden Hund wir fließen mal
direkt weiter mit der nächsten Einatmung
schau nach vorne und bring den rechten
Fuß vor sollte der vorne mal nicht
ankommen gerne rechte Hand an die Wade
Fuß nach vorne bringen falls zu Hause
Probleme gibt dann Schwung von links
hüftschmal daneben ganze Vorbeuge
Einatmen Hände an die Schienenbeine
Oberkörper hoch langer Rücken Ausatmen
ganze vor
Einatmen Knie anbeugen komm Schwung V
hoch zum Stehen nimm die Arme mit und
ausatmen die Hände malch vor dem Herzen
zusammen mal ganz kurz die äugelin
schließen wir arbeiten Yoga gern mit
Intention vielleicht hast du jetzt für
heute noch mal für deinen ganz eigenen
Weihnachtstag eine Intention irgendetwas
worauf du dich heute fokussieren
möchtest das können die einfachsten
simpelsten Sachen sein sowas wie Ruhe
bewahr
nicht stressen
lassen versuchen zu lächeln was auch
immer schau mal was da gerade intuitiv
da ist und dann halte mal diese
Intention fest und verinnerlich und
manifestiere diese Intention für dich
für deinen ganz eigenen
Weihnachtstag und schenk dir selber noch
mal so ein schönes Lächeln hier
schon
Gelassenheit aber auch Vorfreude
vielleicht schon so ein bisschen schauen
wir nicht nur ganz so negativ in den Tag
sondern eigentlich freuen wir uns ja
auch auf die Geschenke später
richtig genau dann geht das Lächeln
gleich noch ein bisschen weiter g mit
der nächsten Einatmung öffne die Augen
und Z die Arme nach oben Lang Lang Lang
Lang Lang Lang und Ausatmen wieder in
die vorbeugeefingerkuppen zum bunden
Einatmen Hände an die Schienbeine
bringen wir die Hände an die Schienbeine
nicht an die Knie genau super immer ein
bisschen besser dann mit der Ausatmung
jetzt mal die andere Seite Fingerkuppen
zum Boden linker Fuß weit weit zurück
großer ausfschritt rechter Fuß daneben
schiefe Ebene halt hier noch noch mal
für eine Einatmung mach mal den Bauch
richtig schön fest und dann mit der
Ausatmung Knie zum Boden Ellenbogen
ziehen nach hinten Brust und kindin zum
Boden Einatmen in die Kobra Schambein er
Füße lang lass hier die Rumpfmuskulatur
Arbeiten Ausatmen Stück die Zehen um und
komm wieder zurück in den
herabschauenden Hund mit der nächsten
Einatmung für den linken Fuß nach vorne
du kannst auch gerne links schon auf die
fingeren kommen ist einfacher rechts
daneben hüftschmal ganze Vorbeuge
Einatmen noch mal die halbe Vorbeuge
schieb den Rücken richtig lang lang raus
Ausatmen noch mal ganz Z Vorbeuge komm
Schwung vor hoch zum Stehen mit der
Einatmung Knie einbeugen Arme mit
Ausatmen Hände vor dem Herzen zusammen
Einatmen noch mal die Arme nach oben
ziehen richtig schön lang machen
aufgepasst Ausatmen für die Hände über
die Seite nach hinten zum Kreuzbein und
macht da mal eine Faust für euch ich
zeig ihr macht das ja die Faust nach
unten ein Einatmen lang machen sehr
schön Herz öffnet sich das Herz öffnen
für all das was kommt heute Ausatmen
beug die Knie an und lehn dich nach
vorne in die ganze Vorbeuge noch mal die
Arme über den Kopf fallen lassen Kopf
ausschütteln locker locker Gewicht me
auf dem vorderen Fuß deen die Schultern
hier noch mal ein bisschen auf die sind
nämlich schnell verspannt ne wenn wir
uns ärgern Anspannung Stress ist haben
wir immer Probleme im Schulterbereich
lösen wir noch mal dann langsam die Hand
die Hände zum Kreuzbein führen die Faust
lösen
mit der Einatmung Hände an die
Schienbeine noch mal halbe
Vorbeuge und dann Ausatmen Fingerkuppen
zum Boden rechter Fuß geht ganz weit
nach hinten achtet mir drauf das linke
Knie ist über dem linken Sprunggelenk
jetzt legen wir ganz achtsam langsam das
rechte Knie zum Boden ab und komm nach
oben hoch mit dem Oberkörper nehmen die
Arme mit und jetzt lassen wir uns mal
sinken denen hier mal ein bisschen die
Hüfte auf ist auch super wenn wir viel
sitzen gerade zur Weihnachtszeit haben
wir ganz oft pro Problem in der Hüfte
desw noch mal schön hier die Hüfte
aufmachen Finger gern spreizen yes
richtig schön lang machen atme tief ein
jetzt lass un mal das Herz öffnen
kaktusarme mal richtig schön hier hinten
zusammenziehen Herz öffnen die Vorfreude
da vielleicht ein bisschen Freude auch
auf die lieben die ihr sehen werdet die
ihr lange nicht gesehen habt mit der
Einatmung noch mal lang die Arme nach
oben und mit der Ausatmung Umrah wieder
den vorderen Fuß heb dein rechtes Knie
an bring den linken Fuß nach hinten
direkt in die schiefe Ebene halte für
eine einat
Ausatmen wieder Knie zum Boden Brustbein
und Kind zum Boden Einatmen in die Kobra
langer Nacken und Ausatmen wieder zurück
in den herabschauenden Hund aufgepasst
Einatmen mal rechtes Beinchen hoch in
die Luft für den sogenannten
dreibeinigen Hund Ausatmen zieh das Knie
vorne ran und bring den rechten Fuß
zwischen deine Hände wie gesagt greif
nach wenn er nicht ankommt achtsam Knie
ü Sprunggelenk linkes Knie zum Boden
Einatmen richte den Oberkörper auf hier
Ausatmen lass dich noch mal sinken
wireden die andere Seite die andere
Hüfte feh spüen Unterschied Finger schön
spreizen aktive Arme tief einatmen hier
und noch mal schön Herz öffnen
kaktusarme hinten Schulterblätter
zusammen super öffne das Herz richtig
Einatmen Streck die Arme nach oben und
ausatmen um Rahmen den vorderen Fuß
aufgepasst linkes Knie hoch Schwung V
linker Fuß nach vorne ganze stehende
Vorbeuge sui Einatmen halbe Vorbeuge
noch mal händ an die Schienbein Arme
sind gestreckt Rücken lang Ausatmen
ganze
Vorbeuge Einatmen komm schwungfall hoch
zum Stehen Arme
mitnehmen und ausatmen die Hände vor dem
Herzen zusammen eine Runde geht noch ja
okay Einatmen Arme nach oben wir wandeln
ein bisschen ab ein bisschen anstrengend
Ausatmen in den Stuhl jetzt sürfen die
Arme mal ein bisschen die Beine meine
ich Arbeiten im Stuhl ist wichtig Po
geht nach hinten tief raus und ich sag
immer das ist ein Stuhl es ist kein
barhcker ne also schön tief setzen Arme
sind neben den Ohren Gewicht auf den
Fersen schau mal nach unten heb die
Zehen an dass Du sie sehen kannst genau
jetzt bauchnabe rein kein hohkreuz
bauchnabbe reinziehen merk ihr ein
bisschen was merkst du
was bleiben wir so ca 15 Minuten hier
freuen uns jetzt schon aufs Essen Falls
an Weihnachten kein Tisch kein Stuhl
übrig ist genau ja sehr gute Idee oh men
das ich gut das werde ich gleich bei
meiner Fam mir einbauen und jetzt
Ausatmen fingerguppen zum Boden der
linke Fuß geht nach hinten ich stell mir
gerade vor super rechter Fuß bleibt wo
er ist diesmal Becken bisschen anheben
linken Oberschenkel annehmen Füße
energetisch gesehen zusammenziehen und
dann Oberkörper anheben Arme hoch high
Lunch bisschen tiefer setzen genau jetzt
hat man es gerade gesehen manchmal
wackelt man dann empfehle ich immer den
rechten Fuß ein bisschen mehr nach
rechts und den linken mehr nach links we
dann steht ihr so zweigleisig und habt
vielleicht nicht so das Gefühl zu zu
wackeln ja bisschen tiefer setzen Arme
strecken Finger spalzen sehr gut schieb
diee Fersen nach hinten vorne tief
setzen atme tief ein und ausatmen wieder
Fingerkuppen zum Boden um Ramm den
vorderen Fuß diesmal in den
herabschauenden Hund sehr gut vom
herabschauenden Hund Einatmen vor
schiefe Ebene und ausatmen Knie Brust
beim Kind zum Boden Einatmen in die
Kobra und ausatmen wieder zurück in den
herabschauenden
Hund jetzt linkes Bein Einatmen
hoch Ausatmen Knie ranziehen zum
bauchnabe Blick nach vorne feht links
auf die Finger gucken kommen linker Fuß
geht vor vielleicht hier gleich linken
Fuß ein bisschen mehr nach links rechts
mehr nach rechts versetzen Oberschenkel
rechts anheben Bauch aktiv schwungvoll
hochkmen genau bisschen backeln ist aber
auch erlaubt ja im Leben läuft ja auch
nicht immer alles stabil deswegen hier
schön aktiv Arme gestreckt Finger
gespreizt Schultern nach unten ja
Lächeln super Daumen hoch tief einatmen
hier Ausatmen he nach vorne rechter Fuß
geht vor ganze stehende Vorbeuge und von
hier aus kommen jetzt mal in den Stuhl
setz dich tief nimm die Arme hoch und
noch mal schön Baby Hocker Baby Hocker
Baby Hocker tief tief tief genau für die
Oma die ist ein bisschen kleiner
bisschen tiefer
ne tief ein und ausatmen ganz langsam
kommt zum Stehen Hände vor dem Herzen
zusammen
genau so ihr Lieben spätestens jetzt
hoffe ich seid ihr wach habt Energie für
den einstehenden Einkauf Essen kochen
was auch immer viel Spaß happy
[Musik]
Christmas Halloe und jetzt sitzen wir am
Weihnachtstisch beim Essen und die
ersten Geschichten treten auf die ersten
Nerven Bemerkung von Mama Papa und Co du
am Tisch sitzt und
denkst was mache ich jetzt schrei ich
los knal ich ihr oder ihm eine haue ich
ab versteck mich unterm Tisch schließ
mich im Klo ein was auch immer dir
gerade durch den Kopf geht an diesem
Weihnachtsessen an diesem Tisch wir
kennen das wirklich alle habe ich jetzt
ein Tipp für euch und eine Übung um
einfach mal wieder runterzufahren alles
auszublenden ja und zwar du sitzt am
Tisch es es kurz vor der
Eskalation gibt's eine super Atemübung
der ein oder andere kennt sie vielleicht
im Yoga nennen wir sie n die schod oder
die Wechselatmung ich will ganz kurz
erklären ihr müsst jetzt no nicht
mitmachen und zwar atmen wir da immer
abwechselnd durch das linke und rechte
Nasenloch ein und man kann die Hände
dafür nutzen indem du immer den Daumen
an das rechte nasenlch und den
Ringfinger ja jetzt ist das natürlich
sind aufwendig wenn du es am Tisch
machst wartet mal Leute kurz Stopp hier
ich ma mal ne machst du das visuell das
heißt du visualisierst das ja du
visualisierst über das linke Nasen noch
einzuatmen über das rechte aus und dann
übers Rechte ein und aus machst es kurz
dafür musst du nicht mal die Augen
schließen das würde so aussehen als
würdest Du gerade trotzdem noch da sein
und zuhören wollen wir es mal probieren
okay pokerf pokerf genau hinten da er
Ferdinand was so was wer weiß Mama Papa
alle streiten und du sitzt da und merkst
erstmal schön bitte Gesicht entspannen
du sitzt am Tisch und erstmal schön hier
Zahn rein voneinander lösen das das
erste was passiert lös die mal und jetzt
konzentrierst du dich einfach auf dein
linkes Nasenloch und atmest mal über
dein linkes Nasenloch
ein und versuch mal über das rechte
auszuatmen nur zu visualisieren ärger
dich nicht wenn es nicht funktioniert
und dann atmest du einfach wieder über
das rechte Nasenloch
ein und über das linke wieder aus und
dabei kannst du auch ganz entspannt
Lächeln atmest über Links wieder
ein und atmest über rechts wieder
aus und du merkst schon musst vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr lächeln noch mal über
rechts ein
über Links aus Mutti freut sich dass es
dir gut geht Papa freut sich auf einmal
die Stimmung erhält sich wieder am Tisch
und wenn das nicht hilft die Hände kann
man mal kurz unterm Tisch verstecken
dann vielleicht erinnert ihr euch
Mantra und deine Hände wieder V ganz
kurz vor der
Eskalation Frieden beginnt bei mir
runter am Tisch und dann einfach das
Mantra so ein paar mal für dich
wiederholen und dabei die Fingerkuppen
berühren lassen schön lächeln einfach
mal ganz ruhig Fokus auf dich weg von
den anderen
ah kriegst du jetzt gerade gar nichts
mit vom Gespräch weil du bist so mit
deinen Fingerkuppen mit deinem Mantra
beschäftigt oder mit deiner Atmung dass
du dich gar nicht mer weiter aufregen
kannst und das machst du so lange
vielleicht machst du es auch den ganzen
Abend also zwischendurch vielleicht mal
essen und kriegst gar nicht mit was da
gerade abgeht vielleicht machst du auch
eine kurz Z Beruhigung ein paar Minuten
spür mal
[Musik]
rein
halliallo und herzlich willkommen jetzt
am Abend kurz vor dem Bettgehen am
Weihnachtstag total voll gefressen das
kennt ihr alle Flle Gefühl weil keine
Ahnung wie viel gegessen und was we
nicht was gibt's bei jedem in
Deutschland gibt's ja unterschiedliche
Sachen Bauch ist voll und eigentlich
denkst du oh mein Gott was mache ich
jetzt die Plauze muss weg gibt's ja auch
Yoga superübung um die Verdauung
anzuregen und zwar immer gut Twist
sämtliche Art Twist jetzt kannst du die
Twist einfach gerne im Sitzen machen ne
ich zeig mal so ein paar Varianten und
zwar einfach im Schneidersitz kannst du
sitzen und einfach nur mal nach rechts
drehen einfach nur rüberdrehen und da
bleibst du eine ganze Weile nimmst so
ein paar
Atemzüge genau atmest tief ein und
aus wechselt natürlich dann irgendwann
rüber zur anderen Seite atmest dort auch
immer in den also in den Haltung
empfehle ich so mindestens 10 Atemzüge
zwischen 10 und 20 Atemzüge und dann
geht's dann da drin auch schon so
langsam los ne haben wir so ein paar
Twists also ich möchte euch jetzt ein
bisschen mehr Sachen mitgeben die liegen
und im Bett machen könnt deswegen
bleiben wir unten ja das kann man auch
im Bett sitzend machen ist gar nicht so
schlimm geht ganz gut dann kommst du
nach vorne wieder dann habe ich eine
andere Übung wir machen noch ein anderen
Twist aber der ist ein bisschen
intensiver die Übung aber ich würde
sagen give it a try wir kommen mal
runter von unserem
Sitzkissen du darfst jetzt sitzen
bleibenessa ich hole uns mal gerade ein
Block ihr zu Hause habt jetzt vielleicht
nicht den Yogablock aber Decke zwei
Varianten und zwar du kannst auch GLE
wenn du magst wess einmal kurz zuschauen
und i zu Hause auch wenn ihr nicht so
ein Block habt mit dem Block oder Irin
Buch ist ein bisschen intensiver dann
könnt ihr eine Decke nehmen und die
Rollen das ist ein bisschen entspannter
pass mal auf ich gebe dir mal die Decke
für dich und ich ma mal für mich das
Saso okay jetzt bringst du die
deckenrolle in die Mitte deiner
Matte und die im Block haben oder etwas
härteres auch Mitte was jetzt machen wir
legen uns mit dem Bauch da
drauf ich weiß ist unangenehm bisschen
ja deswegen musst du gleich mal schauen
wie lange du das aushätst aber das ist
eine super super Massage für die
Bauchorgane jetzt nicht direkt nachdem
du gegessen hast also aber hast du jetzt
gerade schon Zähne geputzt und blaaa bis
nach Hause gefahren bisschen Zeit ist ja
vergangen und dann legt man sich da
einfach drauf richtig drauf legen mit
dem
Bauchnabel jetzt kann man am Anfang auch
erstmal auf den Unterarm bleiben das ist
ein Biss bisschen merkst du h auf
Bauchnabelhöhe und dann sinken das
manchmal spürt man dann schön auch die
bauchschlagaler die posiert ne das ist
entspannend ich lieb es oh man SPT
sie und dann kannst du es natürlich
intensiver machen ne nach unten gehst
richtig ablegen jetzt richtig Stirn zum
Boden
bringen und dabei jetzt mal ich komme
das hoch damit ihr mich seht D mit Mikro
funktioniert richtig sinken lassen
Schultern entspannen genau und richtig
die Decke genau merkst du schon ne mm
und einfach da drüber richtig schön
liegen
bleiben genau ich ma jetzt bei mir auch
schon auch wenn ich noch Unterarm bin
aber der Block ist natürlich super super
intens ne
[Musik]
mhm aber das ist auf jeden Fall das
hilft und das würde ich auch empfehlen
bisschen länger zu machen weil man merkt
das vielleicht merkst du auch wenn das
man lässt immer mehr los ne immer noch
mal ein bisschen tiefer senken und noch
mal ein Millimeter und noch mal mehr und
noch mal mehr und noch mal mehr das
fühlt sich an wie ein entspannungsknopf
mh das finde ich auch gut das muss wir
merken muss jetzt mal in Stunde wir
machen den entspannungsknopf das die
die heißt so finde ich super ich direkt
neuen
nam genau das könnt ihr einfach macht
eine Minute zi D solange wir das
aushaltet könnt ihr das machen se gut
wenn du das Gefühl hast es reicht dann
kannst du es langsam
auflösen dann ziehst du mal die Rolle
raus oder den Block beiseite und dann
eine letzte schöne Übung die geht im
Liegen die liebe ich auch die mache ich
morgens grundsätzlich mal gerne weil ich
habe auch oft das mal mit dem unteren
Rücken zu tun aber kurz vor
Einschlafen nee tatsächlich ma mal noch
zwei Übungen noch zwei Übungen wir legen
uns auf dem Rücken können wir so bleiben
mit dem Gesicht was egal ihr seht uns ne
und zwar du liegst jetzt ganz entspannt
im Bettchen freust dich schon und dann
machen wir hier einfach noch mal ein
Twist die Arme kannst du ich schieb das
H mal weg sind uns nicht weg die Arme
auf Schulterhöhe so ausstrecken genau
ich ein bisschen höher so die
Handflächen zeigen immer nach oben super
damit die Schultern geöffnet sind dann
hebben wir den Po an versetz den nach
links zieh die Knie zu dir ran und lass
sie jetzt nach rechts fallen ganz
langsam nach rechts wenn die linke
Schulter abhebt dann kann man hier z.B
zu Hause habt ihr immer ein Kissen oder
irgendwas auch zwischen die Knie lien ja
damit wichtig ist die linke Schulter
bleibt am Boden das ist der liegende
Twist du kannst gerne als Option noch
die rechte Hand oben auf den linken
Oberschenkel bringen dadurch kann man
selber hier noch so ein bisschen Zug
ausüben spürst du das das genau das ist
eine Variante wie gesagt zwischen den
Oberschenkeln oder nichts oder unter den
Oberschenkeln ich mach's hier gerade mal
alles vor könnt ihr alles mögliche
ausprobieren ne und dann hier so richtig
ganz tief mal in den Bauch Einatmen
richtig schön dicken Bauch machen
und mal Mund öffnen
[Musik]
Ausatmen n richtig tief in den Bauch
einatmen und nochtig schön
[Applaus]
Ausatmen sehrut letztes Mal hier auf der
Seite tief
ein und
aus dann kommen wir langsam zurück zur
Mitte stell die auf und dann erstmal das
Becken so ein bisschen rüber nach rechts
versetzen den Po Knie ranziehen und dann
die Beine nach links ver lassen
vielleicht wieder ich ma mal das mit dem
Blöckchen hier vor für euch auch zu
Hause und wie gesagt da geht auch ein
Kissen zwischen Oberschenkel ne und dann
die Arme genau ich mach Kissen vor hier
haben wir unser Mini Kissen genau da
rein linke Hand auf den Oberschenkel
rechten Arm nach rechts und dann hier
ganz
entspannt schön in dem Twist tief ein
und aus
atmen tief in den Bauch ein wichtig ist
dass ihr wirklich spürt mit der
Einatmung dass der Bauch
rausgeht und mit der Ausatmung geht der
Bauch nach
innen tief
[Musik]
ein und schön
aus zweimal mehr hier auf der Seite tief
ein und vollständig
aus
letztes Mal hier tief
ein einmal geht noch und lösend aus die
Anspannung Anstrengung rauslassen das
könnt ihr auch natürlich viel viel
länger machen ne dann langsam zurück zur
Mitte und die Füße aufstellen Becken in
die Mitte bringen und jetzt noch eine
wunderbare Übung wenn wie bei mir zu
Hause vielleicht das Bett an der Wand
steht wie es bei dir mhm steh an der
Wand ja dann könntet ihr rein
theoretisch einfach die Beine an der
Wand hoch wir haben jetzt keine Wand
deswegen nutzen wir den Block vaness du
nimmst dir einen Block ich nehme mir
einen Block und dann hebst du das Becken
an und bringst den Block unter den
Kreuzbein genau kannst der flachen Höhe
Block wenn ihr zu Hause geht auch mit
dem Kissen ich ma mal die Variante mit
dem Kissen vor Kissen geht auch und das
Kreuzbein und dann wir nennen das im
Yoga viarita carani die Bein einfach
nach oben ganz entspannt das Liebe
genau das ist eine Entspannungsübung
auch ist auch super und vor allem im
Bett liebe ich das an der Wand zu
machen ist eine super entspannungsrübung
warum das beruhigt unser
Nervensystem das Blut fließt von oben
nach unten in den
kopfbein ruhiger man wird ruhiger man
wird entspannter gehört ja zu den
sogenannten umkehrhaltung und
umkehrhaltung beruhigen den Geist und
sind super Schlafstörung auch gerade
wenn man vielleicht gestresst war an dem
Tag
heute richtig schön na un sinken und das
kann man ruhig so ein paar Minuten
machen irgendwann wenn wenn die Wand da
ist ist es noch entspannter wieso und
wann merkt man schon wird immer müder
immer
müder h kann das richtig schön
genießen und da bleibt ihr auch so lange
drin wie ihr wollt und dann wenn ihr das
Auflösen wollt dann an der Wand müsst
ihr über die Seite runtergehen und wir
machen das so indem wir die Fersen zum
Gesäß bringen und dann die Füße langsam
aufstellen
dann das Becken anheben blockkissen was
auch immer ihr genutzt hab rausnhmen
Wirbel für Wirbel abrollen und dann gern
unten noch mal nachspüren indem ihr die
Füße Matten breit aufstellt und die Knie
so zusammen fallen lasst einfach und
dann vielleicht mal eine Hand auf dem
Bauch noch mal legen da wo uns
Verdauungsorgane sind und die anderen
vielleicht auch noch mal aufs Herz und
mal reinspüren den Unterschied jetzt
wahrnehmen vielleicht bist Du ruhiger
vielleicht merkst du schon dass es ein
bisschen im Buchlein rumpelt nach den
paar Drehungen und der Massage vom
Bauch dann hoffe ich euch geht's gut
eurem Damen geht's gut und die Fresserei
kann morgen
[Gelächter]
weitergehen eine gute Verdauung genau
eine gute
[Musik]
Verdauung so ihr Lieben hallo und jetzt
ist der Tag zu Ende und die Idee jetzt
ist sogenannten schawasser ne das ist
die Endentspannung im Yoga den Tag noch
mal zu reflektieren und vor allem aber
auch zur Ruhe zu kommen ihr seht jetzt
hier die Liebe Vanessa schon vorbereitet
im schwassa ne genau hat sich schon
zugedeckt das empfehle ich ihr meine ihr
liegt ja wahrscheinlich im Bett zu Hause
ne habt euch auch zugedeckt ganz kurz
noch mal zum einrichten wenn ihr im
schawasser im Yoga oder jetzt auch im
Bett schaut man dass die Beine ein
bisschen weiter geöffnet sind dass die
Zehen nämlich so schön entspannt nach
außen fallen können warum wenn die Zehen
nach außen fahren kann auch das Becken
und der unter Rücken bisschen besser
entspannen nimm gern die Arme rechts und
links neben dem Körper und dreh die
Handflächen nach oben dass das Herz
geöffnet ist du kannst auch gerne den
Brustkorb noch mal anheben die
schulterbeden zusammenziehen und dann
den Brustkorb sinken lassen vielleicht
wenn du jetzt so richtig kuschlichig im
Bett bist vielleicht rollst du noch mal
auf dem Hinterkopf so von rechts nach
links und dann kommst Du irgendwann in
der Mitte an die eäugelen sind
geschlossen man kann sich auch gerne
immer was auf die Augen legen wenn ihr
habt ein Tuch oder vielleicht habt ihr
sogar ein Augenkissen ja das hilft auch
wenn die Gedanken noch ganz doll unruhig
sind weil der Tag so ereignisreich war
und so viel Stress noch gebracht hat und
vielleicht Streitigkeiten dann empfehle
ich etwas auf die Augen zu legen und um
die Augenlieder zu beschweren hilft dir
auch die Gedanken ruhiger werden zu
lassen und wenn du jetzt hier im
schwassana in der sogenannten
Endentspannung angekommen bist dann
lässt du erstmal alles los und das wo
ich dich jetzt Einladung W erstmal
spürst ist dein Körper nim mal dein
Körper jetzt wah und lass mal so richtig
in den Boden sinken nach unten
vielleicht willst du auch noch mal so
ein aussufzen machen noch mal so oder ha
was all noch raus wir jetzt Anstrengung
Anspannung was da noch so drinne ist auf
jeden Fall loslassen
genau und dann nimmst du jetzt den kpper
mal war wie fühlt er sich jetzt
an wie war der Tag
und jetzt wenn du hier so liegst in
deinem schawass im Bettchen der
Weihnachtstag ist zu
Ende lade ich Dich mal ein an die
schönen Momente zu denken die heute
stattgefunden
haben dann neben den ganzen Stress und
vielleicht Streitereien gab es mit
Sicherheit schöne Momente vielleicht das
schöne Geschenk das eine das ganz eine
besondere Geschenk worüber du dich so
wahnsinnig gefreut hast was jetzt gerade
noch mal so direkt lächel ins Gesicht
zaubert wenn du an das Geschenk denkst
wie du es ausgeparkt hast gesehen
hast und vielleicht denkst jetzt auch
noch mal an diesem einen besonderen
Menschen den du heute gesehen hast den
du vielleicht lange nicht mehr gesehen
hast auf den du dich auch gefreut hast
und vielleicht kannst Du noch mal an
denen denken und schenkst dir noch mal
so ein Lächeln und spürst wie das Herz
sich vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen
öffnet wie so
Erleichterung sich breit macht im
Körper
such dir diese kleinen schönen Momente
vom heutigen
Tag vielleicht nur meine Erinnerung an
das essen was hat dir besonders gut
geschmeckt was war so besonders yummy
für
dich vielleicht ist noch was übrig
geblieben vielleicht kannst du dich
drauf freuen dass es das morgen noch mal
gibt wobei Weihnachten Reste essen
weniger
aber schönes Essen leckeres Essen der
eine besondere
Mensch das besondere Geschenk und
vielleicht gab es auch noch sowas ganz
anderes für dich so ein ganz anderen
special moment heute an den du jetzt
gerade noch mal ganz ganz gern
zurückdenkst und dich daran erinnerst an
diesem Moment vielleicht war es ein
Gespräch vielleicht war es eine
Yogaübung die du gemacht hast vielleicht
war es ein Spaziergang den du kurz
gemacht hast vielleicht war es ein
lustiger Moment wo du gelacht hast wo
andere gelacht haben was weiß ich was
auch immer vielleicht gab es diesen
einen ganz besonderen Moment an den du
dich jetzt gerade noch mal erändern
kannst und halte diese schönen Dinge
diese schönen Momente für dich hier im
schawassen fest und spür jetzt
vielleicht auch so eine Leichtigkeit die
sich breit macht es geht auch darum es
geht ja jetzt morgen weiter sind ja noch
zwei Tage Weihnachten das du
erleichtert aber mit offenem Herzen auch
in die nächsten beiden Tage
gehst und dich vielleicht auf andere
schöne Momente noch freust vielleicht
auf andere Menschen die noch kommen die
du begegnen wirst die du treffen willst
oder wirst mit den du dich verabret
hast besondes Weihnachtsessen was noch
ansteht morgen oder
übermorgen noch vielleicht weitere
Geschenke
Überraschungen so dass du jetzt voller
Vorfreude bist auf all das was jetzt
noch kommt und auch Dankbarkeit ganz
wichtiges Thema grundsätzlich ist
Dankbarkeit und das ist das letzte wozu
ich dich jetzt noch mal Einlader für
heute spür mal rein wofür du jetzt in
diesem Moment für diesen Tag was wofür
bist du jetzt gerade besonders Tank war
jetzt in diesem Moment an diesem Tag an
diesem Weihnachtstag so ein bestimmte
Sache Mensch was auch immer wofür bist
du besonders
dankbar
vielleicht visualisierst du das von dem
inneren Auge kannst spüren sehen fühlen
was auch
immer super lass die Augen ruhig mal
noch geschlossen und bringen wir die
Handflächen zusammen wenn du liegst und
jetzt zeen Zeugen wir noch mal ganz viel
Energie indem wir die Handflächen mal
aneinander reiben ganz schnell ganz ganz
schnell richtig dass du merkst
geschlossene Augen du erzeugsttig schön
Hitze Hitze Hitze Hitze Hitze bis es
richtig hott hot hot wird und jetzt leg
beide Hände mal auf dein Herz und nimm
mal die Energie jetzt W spür
mal die
Dankbarkeit die Liebe vielleicht für
dich wel ich das Mitgefühl für
andere spür mal
rein dann noch ein letztes Mal die Hände
aneinander Reim noch mal ganz schnell
letztes Mal richtig schnell schnell
schnell schnell schnell Reibe Reibe
Reibe Reibe wir erzeugen Hitze und
Energie und jetzt legst du die Hände wie
so kleine Schalen über deine Augäpfel
einmal so rüberlegen nimm die Energie
und Wärme wahr und jetzt hast du ganz
geschützten Blick lass die Hände mal so
über dein äugelin und öffne die Augen
ganz
langsam lass dir ganz viel Zeit um
langsam zurückzukommen die Hände zu
lösen und aus dem schawassin
herauszukommen
an dieser Stelle sage ich vielen Dank
happy Christmas und gute
Nacht ich könnte jetzt auch Einschlafen
ja
tschüs